hey johnson
nice johanneson nice guess
who's got a nice
i gotta stop
[Music]
nice this game was created solely
for the purpose of improving our skills
it is not perfect and we are doing all
we can to improve it
game about trumpets hello everybody my
name is markiplier and i picked this
game because in high school i played
trumpet and i've never heard of a
trumpet-based horror game but if there's
any game that i should play it's me
because i was first chair trumpet so
suck at everyone else i was the best
in high school of my high school of
which there are many but if you don't
think that you're the best even if
you're not in the first chair in
trumpets then you're not a true trumpet
anyway so shut up
but don't because you're a trumpet
and you never shut up this game consists
of many loud irritable and overall
terrifying sounds also contains multiple
intense jump scares do not play if you
have any pre-existing hearing or heart
condition problems
nice flashing lights may appear as
well do not play if you have a high risk
of nice may not run well on some
nice
nice this game is a demo thus does
not save contains a few lighting errors
what does that mean what does that mean
follow the sounds
oh hi
how's it going
swings why is it a death metal swing
album
no i see
ah you play the sounds and then
swings appear
i remember the slide in the woods
that was fun
[Music]
that wasn't a trumpet
i would know i was first chair
but i'm used to only hearing sounds out
of my left ear because i was all the way
over on the right in the first chair
position
up top not me all right nice
okay open
there seems to be a supreme lack of
trumpeting happening
hello
what am i hearing why is the lights all
flashing
that's not a trumpet either you're
playing out a tune up there
zeus
four
shover
nice in it i'm so sorry i don't
know why it's been stuck in my head
i mean it's not the greatest thing to
have stuck in your head
it's
the nicest though okay what opened
[Music]
oh
all right
cool oh my vision's getting all worbly
no it's not no i'm fine
oh no sorry
sorry it's been a while since i did
i just lost a recording i literally did
because i forgot to unmute my microphone
like that's
right i'm playing a horror game
no
all right okay i'm not impressed i'm not
impressed game it's so easy to get out
of practice when you don't
record in a while and then you forget
about the thing
oh okay i thought something was coming
from the curtains over there
[Music]
very nice
okay
nice i gotta get that out of my
head
i don't know why i should probably
censor it no i censored nothing because
i'm a trumpet and we censor absolutely
nothing especially our ability to play
nice all right not bad
nice smiling face of a
fellow trumpeteer i know a happy trumpet
player when i see one
and that was a happy
trumpet player
oh hi
anyone else gonna pop out of me
i can't see i'm staring directly into my
light i know it says light and the irony
of that is not lost on me but i can't
see you i'm assuming that when i get
this in it's gonna turn on the lights
because i can't see anything
there we go
hello
please
oh there we go flashlight is good
oh hi
well that's nice
oh wow
all good
all right
hi
hello
i'm assuming i'm still supposed to
follow the noises even though that has
proved to be an unsavory tactic for me
not very good for my survival
[Music]
okay strange sounds are being heard all
around the world many areas have been
affected by this unsettling natural
phenomenon people report hearing sounds
of trumpets emanating from the sky what
causes this where did these sounds come
from though scientists have created
quite a few theories the majority of
this aspect remains a mystery
i actually didn't take in any of what
was said there developer developer hey
listen to me i could tell that when
either you or you had someone else read
this you had them say area has been
effected which i take to mean that you
spelled it e-f-f-e-c-t-e-d
which is not grammatically correct in
this situation it would be many areas
have been affected a-f-f-e-c-t-e-d
and therefore i didn't take in anything
else because
i don't know why i'm not a grammar
douchebag and maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm
wrong in this you know i always i never
want to be too confident in this but
then again i am a trumpet player and i'm
confident in everything that i do
you want confidence play the trumpet
well yeah and i just thought for a sec
whenever one door closes another opens
[Applause]
okay if i am wrong about that or if i'm
right about that people take equal sides
and fight to the death in the comments
below i will not care either way if i'm
right or wrong once again i am a trumpet
player but you in the comments please
hash it out amongst yourselves i want to
see rivers of blood in the comments
please thank you
they didn't even have trumpets i didn't
see us see a single pad on them anyway
if they had trumpets that would have
been long gone you don't want to stand
in the middle of that
oh i'll really get you i'll really give
you the business
it's been a while since i've been kicked
in the teeth with jump scares like that
i mean i kind of miss games
just literally just ram a jump scare
down your throat
as i say stupid no studio okay
all right studio oh
our studio it is let's go to the studio
record our bang and trumpet album
trumpetsonly.com oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah jim knew okay all right
crew
well
oh i see i bring the crew in
blam
okay oh it's you guys hey
you look like i draw people
you play oh wow
oh
but we're not filming anything unsavory
oh end oh good
well this is a cassette tape and i
was i supposed to look to the right
because i did not
oh your eyes look at me
hey what's up buddy
all right okay
anyway see you around dudes i'll see you
around
gotta go mosey and play them whatever
this is there's two
well that doesn't sound good
definitely don't like it
definitely doesn't sound good
cast
ooh
and demo
end of demo
they did say that this was a demo
but i have seen suspiciously little
trumpet
i was promised trumpets
okay
what wait wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa thank you all for streaming or
making a video of trump it's all the
sportier recruit from our last game
there is nothing here was phenomenal
thank you for giving it a chance i can't
wait to see you all play the full
version of trumpets thanks to markiplier
for majorly promoting our last game
well i'm about to make you take it all
back because where were the trumpets
it's in the name and i didn't see a
single trumpet i didn't see a single
trumpet i didn't see a single one
where's the trumpets plot of the game is
to find the sources of the trumpet
sounds and destroy them completely what
trumpets
where were the trumpets i didn't see any
i didn't notice any i didn't see
anything that had to do with any kind of
a trumpet i gotta go look up my own
trumpets because i clearly didn't get
enough
trumpets too many
no not that jesus christ see the
trumpets of hohn
i don't know what this is
[Music]
oh yeah this is what i'm looking for
anyway that's what i call trumpets let's
see loudest trumpet
[Music]
that's what i was looking for that's
exactly what i'm looking for
thank you aiden de la fuente anyway
that's it for now thank you everybody so
much for watching this has been trumpets
uh i got nothing else to say about it
there's a link in the description that
goes to the game but also
listen to the distractible or i'll blast
a trumpet in your ears and then i'll
blast a trumpet up your ass
and you decide which is worse
nice
[Music]